Çeviri: Bilge Yilmaz
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Caymazer
Karsu
Caz Sanatçısı
Merhaba, hoş geldiniz.
Ben bugün biraz kendimi anlatacağım size.
3 yaşındaydım orada
ve en sonda diyordum ki
“baba daha çok istiyorum,
daha çok istiyorum baba.”
Bu benim sınıf fotoğrafım.
Tek Türk kızıydım okulda.
Sağdaki benim.
Ben gençken yani tek kız olarak okulda
çok da popüler bir kız değildim.
Kıvırcık saç moda değildi
ve annem bana
hippi kıyafetler giydirirdi.
Şimdi, hikayem
nerede başladı anlatabilirim.
İsmim Karsu.
Karsu Dönmez
ve benim babamın,
annemin doğduğu köyün ismi.
Hatay’da Antakya’da.
Benim annem, babam orada doğdu
ve annem 9 yaşında
Hollanda’ya Amsterdam’a göçtü.
Dedem Amsterdam’da çalışıyordu
ve ailesini Hollanda’ya getirdi.
Babam mülteci olarak
20 yaşında Hollanda’ya kaçtı.
Annem babam kariyer yapmak istediler.
Annem spor yapmak istiyordu.
Ama dedem diyordu ki
“yok, kızlar spor yapmaz.”
Babam çok müzisyen olmak istiyordu,
saz çalmak istiyordu.
Ama dedem derdi ki
“yok oğlum doktor ol, avukat ol.”
Müzik çalmak ayıptı o dönemlerde.
Babam ilk kez 21 yaşındayken sazı gördü
ve kendi kendine çalmayı öğrendi.
Benim annem babam tabi ki okula gittiler.
Babam sosyolog oldu,
annem psikolog öğretmeni oldu
ve çok güzel bir hayat
yaptılar kendilerine ve dediler ki
biz iki kızımıza bütün
olanakları vermek istiyoruz.
Spor, kültür, sanat, müzik.
Ben normal hayatımı yaşadım yani
okula gidiyordum bisikletle Amsterdam’da.
Babamın bir restoranı var
Kilim diye Amsterdam’da.
6 sene orada garson olarak çalıştım.
Masa 2 yoğurtlu adana kebap,
masa 5 şiş kebap, hepsini biliyorum.
Ve Kilim’de bir piyano vardı.
Bir piyano.
Ben 7 yaşından beri
piyano çalmaya başladım.
Çünkü piyanoyu çok seviyordum.
Ama kendim için yani başkaları için değil.
Müşteri bir kere duydu,
Karsu, sahibin kızı piyano çalıyor.
Müşteri dedi ki çalmak ister misin?
Yoo, niye çalacağım?
"Ya ne olur bir şey çal."
Tamam dedim, oturdum,
garsonluğu 2 dakika bıraktım
ve müzik çaldım.
Müşteri çok beğendi, ben çok utandım.
Dedim ki hayatım boyunca
hiç, başka yani -- bu sondu.
İkinci hafta yine müşteri geldi.
Dedi ki “ya arkadaşlarımızdan duyduk,
bir kız burada çalıyormuş da.”
Eee, bendim herhalde.
"Evet çalabilir misin?"
"Yoo…" Tamam en sonunda yine çaldım.
Artık her hafta sonu Amsterdam’da,
Hollanda’da herkes konuşmaya başladı.
Bir Türk kızı var –Karsu-
restoranda müzik çalıyor.
Klasik müzik çalıyordum,
bazı pop şarkıları da deniyordum
ve her hafta sonu artık kendim de
beğenmeye başladım çalmayı.
Saat 8’de garsonluğu bırakırdım.
Babam da derdi
“Seyirci, seyirciler kızım bu akşam….”
(Gülüşmeler)
Ve çok güzeldi.
Ondan sonra yarışmaya katıldım.
Kazandım ve o müzik yarışmasında
-piyano ve seste- beni
Amerika’ya davet ettiler.
Carnegie Hall, New York.
Oraya gittiğimde
ben çok heyecanlı değildim.
Çünkü normalde restoranda çalıyorum
yani alışığım artık.
Ama Google’dan baktığımda 1 gün önce,
uçakla gitmeden önce,
Google'dan girdim Carnegi Hall ne diye.
Baktım ki Ray Charles çaldı,
Madonna çaldı.
Şimdi Karsu çalacak.
(Gülüşmeler)
Bayağı heyecanlıydım.
Gittim, konserimi verdim,
geri geldim ve hayatıma döndüm.
Restorana gittim, liseye gidiyordum
ve her hafta sonu çalıyordum.
Ama Hollanda’da
basında acayip bir şey oldu.
Bu Türk kız kim?
Artık restoran her hafta sonu
yemek için değil
– kusura bakma baba–
ama müzik için dolmaya başlıyordu.
(Gülüşmeler)
Benim hedefim yani rüyam
küçükken bir şeydi.
Herhalde bütün kızlar gibi prenses olmak.
Güzel elbise giymek, pırlanta ayakkabılar
ve restoranda çalarken
halen müzisyen olmak hedefim değildi.
Psikolog olmak istiyordum.
Çocuk psikoloğu.
Kilim doluyordu –restoran-
ve çalıyordum.
Dedik ki ailemle, biz bir konser verelim,
insanların hepsi görsün, ondan sonra bitti
yani okula devam ederim.
Konseri verdik 750 kişi,
5 hafta önceden biletler tükendi.
Hayatımda hiç konser vermedim,
çok heyecanlıydım.
Verdik konseri,
dedik ki tamam bitti.
İkinci hafta sonu
yine restoranda çalışırken
dışarıda kuyruk olmaya başlıyordu.
New York’ta iken caza aşık olmuştum.
Babamın aradığı özgürlüğü ben
New York’ta caz müzikle orada buldum.
Artık caz müziği
kendim yazmaya başladım
Kendi şarkılarımı, bestelerimi,
sözlerimi yazmaya başladım.
Dedim ki ben gerçekten
artık müzik yapmayı çok seviyorum,
bayağı da bir kariyer olmaya başladı.
Çünkü insanlar soruyorlardı:
Burada konser yapmak ister misin?
Seviyordum, dedim ki o zaman
daha profesyonel bir seviyeye getirelim,
konservatuvara gideyim.
Heyecanlıydım.
18 yaşında konservatuara “baş” vuracaktım.
(Gülüşmeler)
Aklımda tutmak için
Türk kelimeleri bazen--
(Gülüşmeler)
(Alkış)
Konservatuvara giderken
bayağı bir heyecanlıydım.
Böyle yuvarlak bir yerde
bir şey vardı, durdum.
Müziğimi çaldım.
Dedim ki ok.
Şimdi kariyer profesyonel başlayacak
ve okula alacaklar beni.
Ama almadılar.
(Gülüşmeler)
Çok çok çok üzgündüm,
eve ağlayarak gittim.
Bizde okumak çok önemli bir konu.
Dedim ki şimdi ben ne yapacağım?
O zaman bırakayım yani.
Öğretmenler -3 tane öğretmen duruyordu-
beni daha yetenekli gibi görmüyorlarsa
o zaman öyledir, o zaman hiç yapmayayım.
Ama dedim ki ben bunu
çok seve seve yapıyorum,
gerçekten müzik yapmayı seviyorum
ve çalmayı çok seviyorum.
Eve gittim, 1 yıl kendi müziğimi çalıştım.
Dedim ki Türk müziği güzel,
caz müzik güzel,
klasik müzik güzel,
pop müzik de güzel, blues.
Artık böyle birleştirerek
kendi müziğimi yapmaya başladım.
Çok çalıştım ve daha çok
konserler vermeye başladım.
Ankara’ya gittim ilk kez konser için,
salon 200 kişi.
Hazırdım ilk kez Türkiye’ye,
20 kişi gelmişti.
Düşünüyordum ki yavaş yavaş
iyi gidiyordu müzik
ama halen ben
konservatuvara alınmadım yani.
Hala benim hissime göre
profesyonel değildim.
Hollanda’da- Avrupa’da diyeceğim-
en büyük caz festivaline davetliydim.
20 yaşındaydım.
Benden önce sahnede Quincy Jones,
benden sonra Norah Jones ve Stevie Wonder.
Bayağı bir heyecanlı konserdi.
Ama halen profesyonel
olmadığıma inanıyordum.
Çünkü konservatuvarı bitirmedim,
alınmadım bile.
Konserimi verdim,
baktım ki böyle seyircilerin içinde
bana hayır diyen öğretmenler
bana alkış yapıyordu.
Onlar seyircilerin içinde,
ben sahnenin üstünde.
(Alkış)
Tabi ki yavaş yavaş,
yıllarca çok çalıştım.
Allah'tan şimdi Ankara’da
iki bin kişi geliyor, yirmi kişi değil.
Şu anda 25 yaşına geldim,
biraz yaşlanıyoruz.
(Gülüşmeler)
Mutluyum ki artık
bütün hedeflerime ulaştım.
Artık onlarca ülkede konser veriyorum.
Monako’dan Fas’a,
Brezilya’dan Endonezya’ya.
Artık müziğimle dünyayı geziyorum
ve çok mutlu mutlu yapıyorum.
Çok mutluyum ki--
Konservatuvara alınmadığım için
ve baştan biraz zorluk yaşadığım için
rüyalarımı bırakmadığıma çok mutluyum.
Şimdi ben Karsu olarak -müzisyen değil-
artık vardığım için insanlara
ne geri verebilirim?
Dünyayı kurtaramam kendi başıma.
Ama belki bir şey yapabilirim.
“Connecting The Dots” bugünün konusu.
Annem babam Hollanda’ya göçtü,
babam mülteci olarak.
Şu anda dünyada çok
evden kaçan, ülkelerden kaçan,
ailelerden kaçan kişiler var.
Amsterdam’da yaşıyorum.
Orada merkez tren istasyonunda
her gün Suriye’den,
Eritre’den, Afganistan’dan
mülteciler geliyor.
Ben MasterPeace’in, savaşa karşı
müzik yapan bir organizasyonun
elçisi olarak orada
-göstereceğim size-
her akşam mültecileri bu tişörtle
trenden çıkarıyoruz.
‘Refugees welcome,
we are here to help you’’
Arkadaşlarla bunu -gönüllülerle-
bir buçuk aydır yapıyoruz.
(Alkış)
Şimdi ben müzisyen Karsu
olarak orada değilim.
İlk başlarda da -böyle gitmiyorum yani-
tişörtle, bot ayakkabılar, soğuk çünkü.
Biz 20 kişiyle,
-artık çok mutluyum, yönetmen oldum orada-
söylüyoruz ve duruyoruz orada.
20 kişiyle grubu paylaşıyoruz,
sen Almanya tramvayına git,
sen Brüksel tramvayına git,
sen Paris tramvayına git.
O tişörtü giyip orada bekliyoruz.
Mülteci gelince yemek veriyoruz,
içecek veriyoruz, sıcak ceket veriyoruz,
internet veriyoruz ve gülümse--
We smile. Yes.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ben her akşam yaşadığımı
size anlatırsam burada iki ay otururuz.
Her akşam onlarca, yüzlerce kişi geliyor.
Ama size bir hikaye anlatmak isterim.
Bu, bir buçuk hafta önce oluyor.
Ben aşağıda duruyordum kıyafetlerin,
yemeklerin yanında ve arkadaşları
tren istasyonuna gönderdim.
Anlattığım gibi sen oraya,
sen oraya, sen oraya.
Bir arkadaş geldi.
10 yaşında çocuk, yalnız.
Çocuk 2 kelime söylüyor:
Suriye ve baba.
Ben bakıyorum, diyorum ki
“annen, baban nerede?
Yalnız mı geldin sen, nasıl olabilir?”
Oturttum, yemek verdim.
İki gün yemek yememişti.
Su verdik, oturdu.
Biz şimdi arkadaşlarla düşünüyoruz
biz ne yapacağız.
Sonra çocuk cebinden bir numara çıkardı,
baba dedi sorarak.
Mülteci arkadaşlar benim yaşımda,
iki hafta önceden gelip bize
yardım ediyorlar gönüllü olarak.
Arapça konuşuyor.
Dedik ki şimdi arayalım mı?
Çünkü kimse almazsa bu telefonu, kötü
haber gelirse biz mi vereceğiz çocuğa?
Ama arayalım.
Aradı arkadaşım numarayı ve çaldı.
Çocuk önümüzde oturuyor ve
bende arayan arkadaşın yüzüne bakıyorum
Birisi telefonu aldı.
Baktım, kafasını salladı.
Olamaz dedim, şimdi biz mi
söyleyeceğiz bu çocuğa ne olduğunu.
Telefonu kapattı iki dakika sonra.
Dedim ki babası yaşıyor mu?
Babası Suriye’de mi?
Babası yoksa Macaristan’da mı kaldı?
“Yok” dedi “babası yaşıyor
ve babası Amsterdam’da.”
Aynı şehirde babası,
aynı gün o da gelmiş.
Yarım saat sonra baba ve
oğlu birbiriyle buluştular.
Her akşam böyle anlattığım gibi onlarca,
yüzlerce hikaye yaşıyoruz.
Bu hikaye güzel bitti ama
çok güzel bitmeyen de çok var.
Şimdi ben bütün hayallerimi
seviyeye geldiğim için,
çok mutlu yaşayabildiğim için
düşünüyorum ki bu çocuklar da
aynı hayallerle, aynı rüyalarla
onların da bir şansları olması lazım.
Akşamlar bitiyor tren istasyonunda,
bisikletle eve gidiyorum.
Eve giderken diyorum ki kendime
bu mu hayat?
Why is it so unfair?
(Hayat neden hiç adil değil?)
Eve gidiyorum, bütün akşamı düşünüyorum
ve o sesleri halen duyuyorum
yeni Suriyeli arkadaşlarımın.
Diyorlar ki Karsu ne olur
sen bizim hikayemizi anlat.
“Ben ailemi kaybettim,
cam gibi, ayna gibi paramparça oldum.”
Ben de düşünüyorum
bu hikayeyi nasıl anlatabilirim ki?
Belki bir dil vardır,
evrensel bir dil vardır: müzik.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum dinlediğiniz için.
(Alkış)
(Canlı Müzik Performansı)